pierre guerlain professeur de
civilisation américaine à paris 10
bonsoir pierre guerlain merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france donald trump a
dit qu'il partira si les grands
électeurs valide la victoire de joe
biden le 14 décembre
est ce qu'ils croient encore en sa
victoire à lui non je crois que il est
clair pour tout homme qui a perdu
il fait un petit peu de cirque comme
c'est habituel simplement avec les
démagogues confirmé comme lui il faut
toujours s'interroger pour savoir quelle
est la raison de social alors la raison
la plus évidente c'est évidemment
continuer à actionner sa base qui est
quand même de 74 millions d'électeurs
donc c'est une base qui reste importante
mais qu'il a perdu l'élection
il ya deux élections qui vient de
l'engergie donc là il ya un facteur tout
à fait important je suis des
sénatoriales
oui les sénatoriales qui doivent qui ont
été reportés parce que l'écart des voies
était trop étroit en géorgie donc ça
déterminera si éventuellement les
démocrates peuvent avoir aussi 50
sénateurs et donc avec la voix
prépondérante de l'ex président
la vice-présidente donc d'avoir la
majorité au sénat
donc c'est très important il ya cet
aspect là l'autre aspect c'est
évidemment le narcissisme blessé deux
tomes qui ne veut absolument pas
accepter qu'il a perdu et qui veut
partir en faisant le maximum de bruit et
de fureur
comme il a une fois il dit en ce qui
concernait la corée du nord
des recours en justice qui ont tous
jusqu'ici été dégoûté la pennsylvanie
hier mathématiquement il n'y a plus
aucune chance pour donald trump de
retourner la situation
non on peut penser que ça y est c'est
fini c'est intéressant aussi de voir que
même jeu
je nommais barton ne lui ont pas donné
raison donc cette cette voie là est
fermé c'est clair on va parler de
giovanni donne à présent la plupart des
membres de son futur gouvernement ont
participé au mandat de barack obama
alors certains parlent d'un retour vers
le futur 2 mecs obama great games and du
troisième mandat de barack obama a
conduit vous alors je vous ai trouvé
quand même très gentil dans votre
présentation liminaire
parce que comme le dit une journaliste
australienne qui a un petit peu
dissidente dit une grande diversité dans
l'équipe de bayonne et vous avez
mentionné les femmes une femme
afro-américaine
mais il n'y a pas beaucoup de diversité
idéologie blinken c'est quelqu'un qui a
été pour les guerres en irak en libye
qui est encore plus faux contre
qu'abidal donc il s'entoure de gens qui
sont quand même marqué par soient leurs
liens avec le complexe une leader du cpl
soient leurs liens avec les entreprises
chimiques pour s'occuper de
l'environnement c'est que c'est un
cabinet qui ne tranche pas sur tous les
plans avec celui de chambre sur le plan
de la rhétorique oui alors retour vers
le futur bien sûr ils piochent dans les
équipes obama puisqu'il vient de là
lui-même simplement le monde a quand
même beaucoup évolué et si on prend le
cas de l'iran où il ya donc deux jours
il ya eu un assassinat ciblé dont on
peut penser avec de bonnes raisons
qu'elle était co-organisée par les
etats-unis israël et l'arabie saoudite
un des objectifs de cet assassinat ciblé
c'est empêcher le retour pur et simple
dans le gceip ouais c'est à dire
l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien
de la part de l'administration banale
qui commence à dire il y aura des
préconditions donc même s'il voulait
revenir
ce serait un assassinat au qui aurait
reçu l'aval entre guillemets des états
unis de l'administration trump pour le
coupable mais il ya énormément de
you de fuites dans la presse qui laisse
penser que c'est une possibilité tout à
fait rationnel et si vous vous souvenez
bien il ya quelques jours le new york
times avait fait un article disant que
tu vas me voulait bombarder des
installations nucléaires en iran ce cas
un risque de prolifération nucléaire
énorme pour le monde entier et il
semblerait qu'il se soit rabattu sur un
cinéaste blé d'une personne mais dans
tous les cas créer une situation de
quasi guerre avec l'iran c'est d'abord
mettre le monde en danger mais aussi de
la part de clubs et des dirigeants
saoudiens israélien rendre les choses
plus difficiles pour barry donne il
peut-être n'étais pas très motivé pour
revenir vraiment dans l'accord muller
gros enjeu pour joe biden gérer la crise
sanitaire on a vu que plus d'un million
personnes ont pris l'avion aux états
unis la veille de la fête de
thanksgiving
ça veut dire que une faune l'averse de
la prudence préconisée par john pye jour
dubaï bonn les américains oui alors il
ya une situation où la pandémie tout
appel hors de contrôle et un certain
nombre d'américains
visiblement ne sont pas intéressés par
des mesures barrières efficaces et pour
le moment dans puisque la santé gérée au
niveau des états un grand nombre d'états
ne sont pas du tout responsable
vis-à-vis de la pandémie
donc peut-être que l'équipe by donne va
en démesure dans la mesure du possible
fédéral pour lutter avec des mesures
barrières un peu plus efficace qu'en est
il de la de la latitude de la future
administration les avis de la france
quand on sait que blinken et francophone
est ce que ça va simplifier les choses
alors les intérêts priment toujours les
émotions que blink soient francophones
ou pas lorsqu'il s'agira d' imposer des
sanctions d'entreprises qui font du
commerce avec l'iran blinken sera
d'accord avec il ya eu un article du
monde qui tel n'imaginais pas que les
choses vont être plus que beaucoup plus
facile rapports avec la france
savait il y aura moins d' insulte
notamment public
mais ce qui prédomine toujours dans les
relations entre les états c'est les
intérêts et les grandes déclarations
d'amitié
en fait c'est pour faire du show à la
télévision mais c'est pas ça qui compte
les intérêts de bazré seront là et des
relations avec la russie comment les les
sentez vous on sait que joe biden a été
dans l'administration obama il connaît
bien les relations internationales
qu'elles qu'elles sont le quel est le
type de relation qui pourrait se nouer
avec la russie selon vous alors il ya
deux phénomènes d'abord jusqu'à
l'arrivée de chuck
les relations avec la russie et est
quand même meilleur que sous peu et il
ya eu par ailleurs la fameuse affaire
russe pacha gheit à laquelle by john a
participé jusqu'à très récemment donc
sur un plan en fait obama était un petit
peu plus raisonnables
- plus prêt à garder les accords sur les
armes nucléaires et pas ailleurs pour
des raisons électorales les démocrates
pendant quatre ans ont joué avec l'idée
que la russie aurait déterminé
l'élection en 2007
donc là vous avez deux facteurs
antagonistes on peut supposer quand même
que un tackle de rationalité pourrait
s'imposer notamment sur les accords de
limitation d'armé nucléaire et que les
états unis en arrivent à travailler avec
leurs grands rivaux la chine et les
états et la russie sur des domaines
comme par exemple la pandémie pour la
chine où les restrictions des as sur les
armes nucléaires avec la russie mais
évidemment on peut pas s'attendre à ce
qu'il y ait des relations étroites et et
bienveillante des deux côtés il ya eu
trop de lait trop d'événements ces
dernières années merci beaucoup
pierregarin on suivra cela évidemment
avec vous merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu
à nos questions ce soir en direct sur
arte france